[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas parce que je chantais c'est
parce que
non plus c'est parce que j'écoutais de
la musique
un peu fort enfin il me semble pas non
plus et en plus c'est un duplex tu vois
ce que je veux dire donc j'étais sur le
dernier étage personne ne fuit de moi
mon studio est au dernier étage donc ça
me semblait pas absolument et ben non
j'ai eu des gens qui tambourinaient
voire défoncer la porte est-ce que tu
travailles beaucoup la nuit toi je crois
oui exclusivement en tout cas pour
l'écriture
bientôt la fin de l'année 2022 j'ai hâte
de savoir ce que 2023 va me réserver
tomber amoureux
une autre chose là pour faire autre
chose autre chose un truc mieux
comme dirait Confucius l'homme qui
déplace une montagne
les
les amis on y est c'est ce soir c'est la
finale je suis stressé mais évidemment
hyper excité c'est pour ce moment qu'on
s'entraîne toute l'année
17 décembre sur TF1 on la ramène à la
maison